hello everyone and welcome to a game
that ended very abruptly it uh basically
took only nine moves uh for this game uh
uh to be over even though it took a few
moves extra it was a game over on move
nine and it's incredible how these
things continue to happen even though
it's 2022 and we are you know uh well in
the era of engine preparation and
everyone knows everything uh but still
something like this happens so uh
without further ado let's check it out
it's yesibenko versus shakira mamayarov
in round one
of this year's air things masters uh so
let's check it out the espanko with the
white pieces opens with e4 uh we have e5
by mamedyarov knight to f3 d6 and now d4
so philidor's defense is on the board
and of course not bishop g4 you guys
have all seen the opera house game uh
but rather e captures on the four knight
captures and now knight to f6 we have
knights to c3 and g6 now so this has all
been played before nothing new here
black's preparing to fianchetto the
bishop castle king side bishop to g5
nicely developing the bishop and the
bishop to g7 queen d2 now yesi pink was
saying that he is ready to castle
queenside and now h6 and this is where
the fun uh really happens because the
position is a known one and uh usually
white will retrieve the bishop to f4 or
to e3 and it makes sense you force the
black to make a
weakening in the position and you always
have this
attack on the on the h6 pawn for example
bishop e3 uh it's a little bit difficult
for black castle because the h6 pawn
would be hanging because now it's a
target however here uh ispenko did not
retrieve the bishop to f4 or e3 he
played bishop to h4 and i think this is
uh
primarily what uh the problem is for
mamidorov in this game he got confused
so here we have a castles uh and now we
have queenside castle so now you can see
black and castle uh but he thought that
everything was just perfectly fine just
normal and he continued developing his
pieces he played knight to c6 but now uh
it's only move nine but the game is
completely over for mamedyarov and of
course you guys um i can see why so feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for the espanko while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
yes the queen on a d8 is only defended
by the rook and the knight uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's knight captures and c6 here
mommy there have captured it's pretty
much the only move you have and now
comes e5 and there is nothing for black
to play here uh you can't move the
knight otherwise you lose the queen
you can't move this pawn
if you capture here than just captures
captures and captures with check you win
a lot of material even though okay okay
knights to e4 is very interesting
because you also attack um a wise queen
and the bishop on h4 the problem is the
resulting end game is winning for black
as well if bishop captures and the eight
knight captures on the e2 bishop capture
c7 knight captures an f1 e captures on
d6 creating a monster past pawn uh and
now of course the knight has no escape
squares you have to play something let's
say knight captures rook captures and
you get this position where um white is
up uh only one pawn but it's uh just a
beautiful pass to deep on this
completely winning for white so instead
after e5 mamidarov tried the g5 he said
all right i will sacrifice the knight
and i will try to use this diagonal and
the semi-open b file to my advantage uh
maybe i can win this it is a rapid game
so uh anything can still happen so okay
isabenko accepted the the free knight we
have queen captures on f6 and now bishop
to g3 so now black completely down the
rook uh donna pisa and um
peter lecko said in the live commentary
that uh when he saw the position that he
just didn't know how to rook the v8 if
this is something that mamiyarov did
willingly as he is a pretty wild player
or did he just blunder a piece later on
it was established that it was a piece
binder but of course mavidera will still
fight uh bishop the c4 we have bishop to
e6 now we have bishop back to b3 not
really worried about anything if you
capture we're gonna capture with the a
pawn and then the rook will be well
somewhat useless here so here c5
preparing c4 mommy darv has to try
something now comes f4 now of course
white also wants to break through here
we have c4 and f captures on g5
attacking the queen here and now queen
to f5 mamidarov doesn't want to waste
time recapturing he plays queen to f5 as
he knows the bishop can only come to a4
and he wants to play queen to a5 and
then maybe some bishop captures some c3
or rook capture some b2 ideas uh might
be possible
so g captures on h6 by ac pink now comes
bishop to h8 you don't have anything
else capturing here doesn't do anything
we can show it if you guys enjoy it i
know you guys like it when i show lines
and now for example rook f2c8 we're
going to play a characters on b3 and
nothing good is happening here for black
so instead bishop back to h8 now comes
rook h2f1 now preparing to bring the
rook into the game via the f4 square
rook f4 rook to h4 and so on so queen a5
preparing the idea now the idea is that
if bishop to a4 as the bishop is still
hanging then we can play rook captures
on b2 maybe but still even though it
looks very ugly for white white is
completely fine here and we're also
going to show why because after king
captures yes you can capture here
because the knight is pinned but now
just a3 and there's nothing black can do
here and look at this rook the b8 czech
king a2 and even though all of black's
pieces are attacking that white king
even the bishop this bishop and this
bishop slicing all the way here uh
there's no good move here for black
there's no way for you to make any uh
progress here so it's a very very sad
day for mommy or rather a start of the
day so here uh instead of
going for the defensive bishop a4 we
have h7 check and now you either go in
front of the bishop but that's not
that's not a lot of fun then we can
capture on c4 bishop captures queen d4
check picking up the light square bishop
or you can capture but this isn't much
better now comes rook to f4 as the h
file opened up for the uh rook to use to
attack so here c captures on b3 nothing
better for mamidarov rook the h for
check king to g8 and the now queen to h6
and he was in this position on move 23
that shakhri armada resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
whatever you do either queen to f7 h7 is
checkmate or queen to h8 is checkmate
you cannot defend against both of them
and of course mamadou resigned so really
really incredible stuff and i think this
is exactly what happened here that after
uh challenged the bishop with h6 that
these are known moves and this is an
unknown move and i think this maybe
confused mamadara a little bit as the
knight to c6 is just a terrible terrible
blunder
uh so that's just the the reality of
modern chess people uh study too many
lines and then you no longer even look
at the position you just you know think
you know the line but the the reality is
you actually don't uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys uh enjoyed it it
was a quite uh quite a tough start for
mamadyarov
uh i would like to thank uh uh odalt
lucifer 45 non-commercial ep uh dale
cook anwar the 95 american flag numa and
the david kimura for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day